welcome everyone my name is Stuart DQ
I'm the program director at the Yale
Center for business and the environment
and we're thrilled to have a great
audience here today both in the room and
online welcome to everyone this really
looking forward to today's discussion
we've got a great panel wonderful
moderator and this is part of the Saban
prize save Inventure prize speaker
series and this event in particular is
co-sponsored between the Yale Center for
Business and the environment and the
Yale entrepreneurial Institute now for
those of you who aren't familiar with
the Yale entrepreneurial Institute we
have some of the leaders of that
organization here today Jim and Elena if
you guys could raise your hands for
folks in the room who are interested in
entrepreneurship and want to build a
business start a venture while at Yale
this is the best place to go first to
get all the resources ideas the the
roadmap for how you go about doing this
and this event is part of the ecosystem
that we're building at Yale to support
environmental ventures so the savings
sustainable venture prize speaker series
is a component of the saban prize which
is a twenty-five-thousand-dollar
winner-take-all prize that's awarded
every April to a business on campus a
start-up that's really pushing an
innovative way to develop to make a
profit and to improve environmental
performance and so this is a year-long
competition and opportunity for students
to engage also in the fall and the
applications for this or do on October
28 we have
dia a concept in mind that you want to
be able to move forward we have funding
support available for those types of
ventures for people to be able to put
that on paper get mentorship advice and
support from the Yale Center for
business and the environment so this
event and the coalescing ecosystem
around here we really hope we can help
foster those innovative ideas which can
ultimately make an impact in the wider
world so you know this discussion
transportation in America us
environmental and mobility trends we're
really lucky in this case to have a
professor at the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies who is really
one of the global leaders on figuring
out and understanding how urbanization
comes together in transportation issues
and how you ultimately look at some of
the solutions that that can come out of
this interaction so we'd love to
introduce a Karen Seto who's a professor
of geography and urbanization at the
school for stern environmental studies
she is an expert in urbanization
dynamics forecasting urban growth and
examining the environmental consequences
of urban expansion she's pioneered
methods using satellite remote sensing
to reconstruct past patterns of
urbanization and develop projections of
future urban expansion in particular of
note right now professor Seto serves on
a number of international and national
scientific advisory committees including
as the coordinating leadoff author for
the IPCC fifth assessment report
coordinating lead author for the UN
Convention on biodiversity cities and
biodiversity outlook and co-chair of the
I hdb urbanization and global
environmental change project she's a
wonderful collaborator at Yale and has
really been quite generous with her time
to the center and we're thrilled to have
her moderating this discussion so I'd
like to invite Karen up to introduce our
speakers
well thank you Stuart well I'm really
delighted to moderate the session today
from my vantage point I think there's
probably no single issue more important
than transportation and how
transportation links with urbanization
as many of you know transportation
systems and transportation
infrastructure is really the backbone of
many cities and over the next 20 to 30
years as we see the global urban
population expected to double in size
some projections show even more than
doubling in size what we're going to see
in many developing countries especially
in Asia and in Africa is the development
of new transportation systems renovation
of existing infrastructure and and I
think that it cannot be underscored the
the really overwhelming opportunities
for innovation in this sector probably
more than any other sector this is
probably debatable whether it's in the
energy sector in the transportation
sector one of the trends that we've seen
in the United States that has been
spilling over to other countries over
the last 50 years is this trend where in
the u.s. people generally are
increasingly live in a city where they
don't work or in other words they work
in a place different from where they
live and this the separation of uses
separation of where people live from
where they work really locks in certain
types of infrastructure in terms of
transportation what we have seen in
cities that have really innovative
transportation infrastructure and
technologies are a tighter mix of where
people live in where they work and so
when we see increased uses or increased
mixture of uses with increased density
that's where we see really innovation in
terms of the types of transportation the
modes of transportation that they can
use so I'm really delighted to hear
about the innovations
and new ideas that are coming out of the
private sector in today's talks a few
statistics that I think just to set the
stage in terms of the importance of the
transportation industry in terms of the
environment over the last 35 years the
Global transport sectors energy use has
increased on average every year at about
two and a half percent so that two and a
half percent increase in energy survey
year pretty much parallels a global
economic growth and so we can see that
over the next 30 to 40 years as
developing countries as urbanization
really takes off in developing countries
as we see more economic development in
these developing countries we're going
to really see the transportation sector
take off and at the same time a lot of
the legacy cities the established cities
like New Haven San Francisco New York
we're going to see a trend towards
renovation and new innovations in terms
of existing transportation technologies
and infrastructure so there are really
two different types of opportunities and
challenges in my mind one is for these
rapidly urbanizing cities some of these
are in developing countries some of them
are here in the United States Las Vegas
is a rapidly still rapidly developing
city and and different types of
opportunities and challenges for
established cities cities that already
have their infrastructure transport
infrastructure already laid out another
statistic that I want you to keep in
mind of over the course of this
afternoon's a panel discussion is that
the Global transport sector currently
takes up or uses about thirty percent of
the global final energy demand so about
one-third of global final energy man
goes to the transport sector and so
again I think this as cities continue to
develop and as infrastructure transport
infrastructure continues to develop
we're going to see that the share can
either increase or it actually may
decrease depending on the types of
innovations that come online from the
industry so
this is particularly exciting to talk
about this afternoon well let me
introduce the two panelists that we have
and then I'm going to invite one of them
to come up and provide some opening
remarks we have mark joseph who's the
chief executive officer and vice
chairman of veolia transportation a mark
began his career with the yellow cab of
baltimore where he served as president
and CEO for 20 years and under his
leadership yellow cab grew from a small
local operation into a leading regional
transportation company and I think this
is one of the themes we're going to see
with transportation again paralleling
this trend where people live in a city
elsewhere from where they work that
transportation has to move from being
really a local enterprise to maybe more
of a regional a regional energy prize s
CEO of Viola mark has rapidly
transformed the company into the largest
multimodal transportation company on the
continent he has a directed dynamic
expansion of bus rail paratransit
shuttle taxi and including the
privatization of the New Orleans public
transportation authority as well as the
acquisition and expansion of super
shuttle which serves as 30 airports
across the United States mark is
committed to a values-based leadership
safety and sustainability and he's
dedicated to transforming improving the
quality of life in cities through
well-designed and integrated
transportation our second panelist for
today is Phil skazhi who's the founder
and president of Metro taxi right here
in our backyard Metro taxi is the
largest full-scale for full service taxi
company in Connecticut and they got to
be that way bill says by providing good
service to our clients and beneficial
contracts to our drivers by reinvesting
in Connecticut's taxi industry and by
creating opportunities that offer
drivers the flexibility to meet today's
two and
family demands and I think this is the
other trend that we're going to see that
transportation is about supply but it's
also about demand and we're going to see
significant changes in both the demand
side and on the supply side business New
Haven celebrated Bill skazhi as a 2000 a
try see star and his company Metro taxi
as the 2010 green business leader so
we're really lucky to have bill as a
local expert to talk about the taxi
industry so without further ado I'm an
invite mark joseph up to the stage to
provide some general themes setting the
stage of transportation thank you Karen
good afternoon everyone I am very
pleased to be here my daughter Allison
is here she's a first year at som so I
want to thank all of you at Yale for the
unique opportunity to formally lecture
her I have the she says I have mastered
the art of the informal lecture so now
for the formal lecture so at veolia we
are we are one of the leaders in
environmental services water waste
management energy and transportation and
what cities face today are a number of
problems around the world most of these
problems cities have in common you are
well familiar with this and these have
changed in terms of priority over the
last few years in the case sadly of air
quality air quality in many cities has
has taken a backseat particularly in
America to issues about public funds and
constrained budgets and how to solve
problems since our financial crisis but
the other issues also are still ever
present particularly sprawl traffic
congestion of the time we spend in
traffic as Karen mentioned commuting
from one location to another another
area that's changed more recently is the
issue of energy clearly we have unlocked
tremendous resources which we'll talk
about in the US but one of the things
that all of us are faced with is this
population growth that you can see is
dramatically increase in and has
increased over the past 25 years it's
booming and it will continue to increase
and this is affecting all of our issues
of resources you can see in that one
circle alone that more than half the
world's population lives in that tight
area and so a lot of what we're trying
to develop in terms of transportation
solutions are actually being developed
in China or in other places more rapidly
than maybe what we're doing here in
terms of aging infrastructure aging
systems and how we're changing our
transportation here we know that we have
issues because not only are people
moving to cities but they're generally
moving to the coastal cities and so you
can see that forty-four percent of the
Earth's population lives within 90 miles
of the shore and as i said earlier no
matter what your politics are this is
hitting much closer to home sadly and
how are we going to be dealing with
issues of the rising tides and warming
with regard to energy this is one of the
more exciting things and bill will talk
about a practical use of clean energy
and vehicles but in fact the US
generally has been slow to take
advantage in a transportation sector of
using clean energy and we have an
enormous resource that you can see
really is growing in particular if you
look here we're the leader in current
reserves the blue represents the current
reserve
so and the oranges future so you can see
China has big future reserves but they
fall behind us in terms of current
reserves as does the rest of the world
how we tap into these energy reserves
and solving transportation issues
represents a big opportunity this is an
example of what the impact of this is
rush hour where I live in Washington DC
the the fact is that this is this is
actually Africa which is the fastest
growing from rural to urban but many
cities around the world are facing this
kind of traffic congestion and and
impact on the quality of life just
quickly some of the older solutions
actually are some of the newer solutions
and and you can see the impact of using
bus buses both in terms of less co2 and
also in terms of less traffic the
unfortunate thing for the developed
world in many cases particularly in the
u.s. not so much in Europe where you
have high density markets with lots of
people who are used to a riding public
transportation but here in the US the
the transportation systems bus systems
in particular are more used by people
who are transportation dependent than
new users and we're trying to solve this
problem because you can see all the
advantages of bus not only in terms of
the fuel but also the impact on
congestion the favorable impact on
congestion here's a great story aware a
and one of the issues that Karen has
raised and we'll discuss later is what
do you do in markets that already have a
fully developed infrastructure or aging
infrastructure how can you change those
those markets it takes a tremendous
political will to do that in the case of
Bogota Colombia in the 90s there was
that huge population density 10 million
people it's one of the great examples of
changing a very cost effective system
brt bus rapid transit some of you are
familiar with that we operate brt
systems including this one in colombia
there were 28 thousand buses that were
operated by thousands of companies with
no organized system travel times were
very inefficient boarding was very
inefficient service wasn't great and
there was a tremendous pollution and
accidents and there was a commitment to
build a brt system that would completely
revolutionize transportation in bogota
and what happened is the system was
built with headways it's one the
distance between one bus and the next
bus of 90 seconds which is remarkable
the cost to build this brt system using
dedicated lanes which is one of the
advantages of BRT if you're in a bus
rapid transit in like we operate in Las
Vegas or in New York just outside of
Toronto or in or in Bogota if you have
dedicated roadway then the vehicles can
travel very quickly in other cities you
might have synchronization with lights
and light preferences where the lights
will change as we do in Toronto for
buses but as long as we can travel fast
it's enormously attractive the other
attraction is the cost to build eight
million dollars per mile to build versus
this says a thousand times that's
probably subway there may be examples of
that but a rail tunnel for a typical
train is a hundred million dollars a
mile and structure about 50 million
dollars a mile so when you see this
boarding system all of its off off bus
boarding prepaid you jump on the vehicle
and go level boarding so you can step
right from the platform onto the bus and
you can see how we avoid the traffic
congestion in Bogota and the impact is
that we transport over 1.7 million
passengers each day with a forty three
percent drop in air pollution 33 32
percent decrease in travel time and it
really has transferred
the city its enormous success here in
Bordeaux where we operated for many many
years the problem was what to do about
traffic congestion there was a call for
a for a construction of a highway system
right in front of the bills on right in
front of those buildings on the
waterfront a 12 lane freeway it would
have been very ugly and the mayor
insisted on putting in a light rail
system this is one of the new and and
we'll talk about this later but one of
the advantages in the the Renaissance of
streetcars and we're seeing more and
more of this in the United States
including very soon in Washington DC
where we ripped up the street cars with
the with the push to to put buses in
cities now streetcars are coming back
what's beautiful about this particular
streetcar is the there's no catenary
wires above above ground wires it's all
operated underneath the ground that's
the way the DC streetcar system will
operate and the impact in the city has
been enormous including seeing the city
by rail the friendliness the ability to
change modes and the integration of all
of these other modes just quickly about
New Orleans Karen mentioned that we we
did something very unique in New Orleans
we became the first company in the u.s.
to to privatize the operation of the
public transit system so we are in fact
the public transit agency in the city
post-katrina the city and the system was
devastated it was already enormously
inefficient with the highest operating
costs in the United States and the
lowest operating performance we
convinced the mayor to to let us to put
out a bid Booz Allen did a study and
and the city decided to put out a bid to
privatize the system we convinced the
city that we would be able to secure
funds to expand that streetcar system we
received a hundred million dollars of
state and federal financing one of the
first Tiger grants to expand the
streetcar and last year we we opened the
new streetcar expansion just in time for
the super bowl and we've completely
revamped the system moving on to an
issue I'm sure you're in you'll be
interested in and that is the the impact
of data and an open data not only for
for devices and smart phones and how
people are able to navigate a myriad of
transportation services whether it be
sedans like uber taxis or buses but
here's the impact when cities choose to
open up their data in the case of in the
case of the tea in Boston they decided
to open their data to for developers to
have access to the data of what was
happening with the train system so
within one hour a developer in
integrated the trial data into the
google earth into Google Earth to show
the real-time locations of the bus is
within two days developer integrating
the trial data into a free easily
accessible web page where T riders could
track the buses from any internet
accessible computer within one week a
developer built a desktop that displays
the countdown information for the riders
favorite stop within two weeks a simple
web app was built that displays
countdown information without the need
for a map within five weeks developer
built iphone and android apps that
integrate to the real time data and the
apps cost 99 cents and within eight
weeks to develop or built a system that
delivers real-time data by text message
to any mobile phone so so you can see
that that more apps continue and frankly
in the case of the T this was done a
couple years ago so the speed to market
has improved significantly since that
time I'll wrap up with what
happening in terms of innovation how
many of you are familiar with uber yeah
so Hoover just did a fundraising round
they just got 360 2 million dollars at a
3 billion dollar valuation one of the
highest ever Google was one of the
Google Ventures was one of the leaders
of that round we have a competing
product that we are founders of call
taxi magic we talk about more about it
later but what's the what's clear is
that people are looking for a change the
big change here the int what innovation
has has occurred here is to change the
dynamic from the the taxi company of
which we run about 14 cab companies
delivering the service and and providing
the service and the customer not being
in control the customer calling for cab
waiting for the cabin and wondering if
the cab will show to the customer being
in control with a transparent
application that shows where the
vehicles are and for the individual
drivers to optimize the their
productivity by matching the closest
vehicle with the closest writer so this
is a way of disrupting the taxi industry
and there are certainly others that are
now disrupting uber but it's also a way
of really significantly improving
service which is what that's all about
just a quick word on what's happening in
terms of innovation and disruption it's
from it's happening at a spate we have a
business taxi business that's a hundred
years old I've been in the business for
more than 30 years in the last three
years I've seen more change than in the
30 years and and we have been an early
adopter early adopter years ago with
being the first to put two-way radios in
vehicles the first to put cellular
phones and limousines the first to put
mobile data terminals in taxicabs and
now the rate of change is happening at
an incredible speed and so you're seeing
disruption of the rental car business
with with you know about the zipcar
you're seeing disruption zipcar with
cars to go how
are you familiar with cars to go so
instead of renting a car by the hour you
can rent a car by the minute you pick it
up you drop it off and you leave it and
you you look for your app to see where
the car is and you find it it's and it
can be anywhere in your market how men
are you familiar with lyft and sidecar
so some are familiar with that that
disrupts uber that's using private cars
as taxis whether it's legal or not is
still a subject of debate but it's
interesting in terms of the shared
economy and collaborative consumption
because people are driving their private
cars and picking people up for a
donation right you know we we used to
call donation rides gypsies or hackers
but today it's a donation ride so we're
going to see where it goes but it's in
it's an ingenious approach because
matching supply and demand is one of the
key issues in transportation so right
now in the world's population by over
five billion people have access to a
cell phone that doesn't mean that
everyone owns a cell phone but five
billion people have access to a cell
phone by 2000 and last year in 2012 12
1.75 billion mobile phones were sold by
2016 two-thirds of all phones will be
smart phones and by 2015 7.5 billion
people will have access to phones so
what we can see especially in the
developing world is people have
leapfrogged landlines by having cell
phone's going off the grid we're also
seeing who other ways of going off the
grid whether it's solar or other things
but that leap frogging can teach us
about new ways of transportation because
if everything is going to be done by
smartphones then you can think about the
impact on transportation and the ability
to connect all types of modes of
services one of the key enablers of this
technology just quickly on the
self-driving car
you know Google and others claim that
that in five years you'll see a high
degree of use do you know how many
states have legalized driverless
vehicles ford states have legalized
driverless vehicles neat California
Nevada Florida and I forgot the other
one I we've talked and done work with
Google in this subject it makes a lot of
sense frankly and right now in gated
communities in Florida but they believe
people believe that in five years you'll
see driverless cars our particular level
of interest is about safety and what we
can learn from this in terms of if you
can make a driverless vehicle safe the
Google car has gone over 500,000 miles
without an accident it is inevitable
that there will be accidents it's not
completely foolproof and the lasers are
kind of dangerous that they use from a
safety perspective but it's a very
interesting thing and how this will have
impact on our society one of the most
interesting ones and we looked at this
business some years ago to be a me in
the bike share business I was concerned
about liability but it started off as
sort of a novelty in my mind a novelty
service and it was done as a trade-off
in perris valley ford echo company the
the the advertising firm in order to
renew their light their billboard permit
in Paris they agreed to invest 20
million dollars in bike share it's now
moved to something that's very very
important which taxi still continue to
play a key role on which is the last
mile solution in order to have vibrant
healthy transportation systems you need
to solve the last mile problem and that
is any fixed route train any fixed route
bus when you get off how do you solve
that my son who is a late adopter even
though he's only 22 a late adopter to
public transportation he's early adopter
too many other things but in public
transportation he is slow to move to
this but I he impressed me recently
because he moved back to Washington got
apartment and when he uses the Metro he
now gets off the metro and rides the
bike 10 blocks from the metro station to
his apartment so it's a perfect example
of how you can get someone out of a car
another big change for me is my
generation when we a graduated college
the first major purchase that we wanted
to make was for what car all this one a
car today the first major purchase is a
smartphone and then the next purchase is
restaurant expense lots of restaurants
so the the issue is he's not interested
in a car even though I offered to get
him one that's not something he's
interested and this is the reason this
is a good reason why how do we get
people out of their cars into buses we
try to make it cool this is co2 light
but we're really promoting getting
people out of their cars and thinking
trying to attract other people who are
not thinking about buses to ride buses
and I will end on this okay thank
well thanks marc for setting the stage
there i'm going to ask bill to provide
some may be local bottom-up perspective
on getting people out of their cars and
in particular you can just tell us a
little bit about the taxi systems and
how that actually works thank you I'd be
happy to do that I want to thank Jim and
Elena for inviting me back here two
years ago I had the pleasure of speaking
here along with Marc Klein who
unfortunately couldn't make it today and
we introduced the the taxi business
model but we also at that time
introduced the natural gas component of
a new vehicle that was being made called
the mv-1 and that was for basically for
our reason for purchasing that was the
the wheelchair accessible transportation
so thanks again for having me back and
I'm going to react free touch more of a
continuation of that but first I thought
what I would do is mark gave a great
great presentation on the larger scale
of transportation systems and issues and
I thought that I would start by
basically just giving you an inside look
at our industry from the taxi stand
point and locally right here in New
Haven Metro taxi was actually we're 26
years old this month it's a family-run
business my wife Isabel is here with me
she's vice president of our company and
we run it together and locally we
produce about one and a half million
passenger ships per year which is
roughly 4,000 per day we transport that
4,000 per data is typically about 800
advanced reservations so mostly where
our demand response of Transportation
and in our view as Mark was saying about
the last mile demand response is really
what our niche is and also we're a lot
difficulty arises in providing a
streamline service reservations are
easier to to comply with advanced or
demand response is a little more
difficult we offer taxi service we offer
black cars through the service we have a
large student transportation service we
do medical livery trips taxi top
advertising and also service to all the
tri-state airports I thought what I
would do is give a brief description
this is really where the technology
piece comes in there isn't so well known
about our industry because I think that
many of us tend to think of the taxi
industry is where it used to be years
ago and right now were you to walk into
our call center you'd see a very very
high-tech environment you'd see phone
operators and one into the room all with
computers taking it a convention for
service and within that we in order to
facilitate that service eighty-five
percent of the trips that you all might
call in just come into our company and
go right out without any dispatcher
intervention role there simply satellite
tracking selects the closest cab it the
closest available cab offers I can't do
a driver the driver accepts it and
you're picked up and it really is a way
to streamline our business and quite
frankly when we did that years ago in
1998 our business really really took off
because we open up a huge bottleneck and
dispatchers basically are sitting behind
a backup computers and they can
literally see every single vehicle that
we own what street it's on they can tell
how fast it's going most of our vehicles
right now have in vehicle cameras and
although we can't view from inside our
office of what that looks like the
cameras are we can't pick up an
indication from a camera when there's
some erratic driving behavior and that
I'll work the dispatcher that there's
either a hard braking situation it may
be an accident or something that we can
retrain our drivers on but the bottom
line is that we're really able to
micromanage our fleet in a way that
we've never ever been able to do before
which has really produced what you all
would like
most of us is a better and higher
quality service so how do the customers
access that service well you know we
have phone all 7s and hopefully you're
familiar with that number but you know
the amount of people that are calling us
on the phone is declining rapidly you
know we have an intelligent voice
recognition system where you don't have
to speak to one of our operators we
offer our own android apps both iphone
and android and in that regard you can
watch your vehicle come to you much the
same way as mark spoke about uber a
short while ago we have web booking
which a lot of our corporate accounts do
so there's a lot of different ways to
there that are facilitating and making
it easier for you to access our service
and again this is common with
large-scale transportation what I refer
to as full service transportation and
taxi companies these are all common
technologies that we're all embracing
one of the things that makes it
difficult for us oh actually before I go
there once the job is dispatch you also
get a text message on your your cell
phone which tells you if your job is
accepted by a cab it gives you the taxi
number and if you've used the app then
you can follow the taxis approaches to
you but in either way you get a
notification when your trip was accepted
and you get an on-site when the call is
out front unit on-site phone call and
you know that your car is out front so
all of these things are meant to make it
faster and easier for use that the taxis
in this industry what that involves
though is all the things that I just
mentioned to you and this is where some
of the big challenges of our industry
come in all of those technologies are
not not owned by one particular company
or entity so our biggest challenge from
Metro taxi stand point was to was to
really marry those all together to form
a cohesive you know start to finish
technology solution for art for our
industry that was that really
facilitates good service and that's the
problem so you have a dispatch company
it's not talking to your phone system
it's not talking to the the app it's not
talking to all the
was the IVR system and all those
different technologies hadn't come
together so that is one of our larger
challenges and we've been able to kind
of swim those waters for a while now but
but our success in doing that has led us
to another part of our business that is
actually taken off very well and we
actually dispatch to right now three
other cities from our location our
headquarters in west haven so we're
dispatching over a thousand taxi cabs in
Chicago in Philadelphia and also in
Manhattan where we have a contract to
provide accessible dispatch service
which we'll talk about a little bit
later on the mobility portion is but
it's opened up avenues to us that we
never would have been able to do before
because literally if somebody's sitting
there dispatching vehicles in our
location it's just as easy to do it in
West Haven as it is in downtown Chicago
or in downtown Manhattan so it's been a
real Avenue and door open for us but of
course our biggest thing is why our
customers calling us and all henges are
going service response times and I think
that's what part of the part of our
conversation is all about because it's
that service reliability that enables
you all to access our service and be
able to rely on the fact that you only
get to where you're going when you need
it two of our biggest projects I'm just
going to touch on slightly because I
think we'll have more conversation and
those one is then are fueling project
two-thirds of our vehicles right now run
on compressed natural gas which is done
great great things for our company for
our drivers for the air quality around
us and the other thing that happened
during during our migration to natural
gas is it opened up the whole door to us
which was a really been trying to get
taken care of for years and that was to
be able to provide demand response
wheelchair accessible taxi service to a
community that it's so so very much
needs that service has needed it forever
continues to need and as we go into
future with the aging baby boomer
population is going to be even
more dependent upon it so no if I went
too fast there's a lot in there there's
a lot to this industry and hopefully
it's a little bit different than what
you may have initially magicked right
thanks Bill well I'm before I opened the
floor for questions from the audience
I'd like to just ask one question to the
two of you ever he said that one of the
themes around transportation is that
people don't other than your Sunday
Drive in the car and generally people
don't want transportation for its sake
what they really want is accessibility
right they want access to services they
want access to get to their jobs or to
some kind of location they want that
it's really accessibility and what I
heard this morning from both of you is
that there seems to be a lot of
innovation that this industry is
actually quite decentralized whether
it's around the technologies to link
supply and demand I'd like to hear from
both of your perspectives what you think
are the necessary governance or
institutional landscapes that enable
those innovations so you know uber and
lyft and innovations in let's say fuel
technologies well those take place in a
particular governance and institutional
landscape right at the local level at
the national level and and what we've
been hearing a lot about in terms of
transforming transportation is really on
the one hand transforming or improving
existing technologies that's more like
marginal changes or a wholesale
transformation of transportation
transportation infrastructure but but we
know that there needs to be an enabling
landscape and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on what that enabling landscape
looks like or maybe what are obstacles
to to those innovations
you can go I think that as far as the
enabling landscape in in in the taxi
industry it's always been driven by the
demand and and that demand changes from
day to day it changes Larry for from
from hour to hour and I think that that
what has driven my company and in our
industry well in Connecticut in over the
place is how do we need that demand and
do it in a way that it's affordable and
it's reliable the innovations that we've
seen on the on the presentation and
marketed through Hoover and through the
other lift companies our industry has
always been doing that and and as Mark
said worthy innovators for the
computerized dispatch the data dispatch
and we've also been the innovators for
exactly the type of phone apps and
technology that they're using now so
we've had those before we continue to
grow those i think i think that the
industry itself produces that i think it
keeps up with it i think that the other
companies may have found the niche that
has a broader broader breath to it
because they contract directly with a
driver rather than go through a central
dispatch but i think all in all our
technology and our innovations have only
been limited by our own ability to weave
that into the the very highly capital
intensive structure that we already
exist in and just trying to move forward
in the best way that we can and i think
a large community successful in doing it
I would say that the first of all the
question is a very important one but
it's also a very broad one because there
are so many different modes of
transportation so one solution from a
regulatory standpoint may apply to one
mode but not to another if you think
about for instance bike-share you don't
see five different companies generally
competing for bike share in a market you
see the municipality licensing a at that
real estate in the city to have the
scale and the coordination it's a
complicated even though it's a simple
basically simple technology in terms of
putting bikes out there the logistics of
managing a bike-share programmer are not
quite that simple but having sufficient
number of locations to serve a community
is important so and in order to attract
the investment there have been there
have been deals that are made to
structure that from a regulatory
standpoint I think one of the keys is to
look at development and where
development is occurring in cities and
where visionary leaders want to see
development occur we see you know the
broad trends of people moving back into
cities interestingly enough the people
who are moving back into cities in the
United States are both older people and
young people and so how do how do
leaders solve the problems for
regulatory standpoint intransitive
licensing or developing new programs
it's very difficult to take away Street
streets for bike lanes very
controversial takes leadership to do
that to do brt it's even tougher to have
dedicated lanes and there are all kinds
of ideas of taking a shoulder of
highways and building lanes on the
shoulders
as far as the disruption that bill was
speaking of the interesting that sort of
dirty little secret on that one is that
the that the the disruptors have said to
hell with the regulators we're going to
try it and then let them go after us and
let's see if we can get and it's an
interesting strategy and for the most
part for a significant part its work to
say let them chase us and we'll by the
time they they get us we'll have enough
of a following that will be able to to
lobby and to fight so it's a combination
of a deep pocket highly paid lobbyists
as well as grassroots advocates but i
would say you have to really think about
which mode you want to talk about and
but then there are different regulatory
approaches to each ok well i see a lot
of folks with their hands ready to go up
so why don't i open the floor for
discussion we have about 15 minutes and
we have someone with a microphone up
here okay if you guys could state your
affiliation and name before a key the
question that would be great so hinge I
say what you on the right hand side oh
there we go
um my name is Allison Joseph that's my
dad um and um first year student at som
and so to follow up on that question I
would ask specifically we've talked a
little bit about energy and clean energy
and i would ask on the electric issue do
you see the leadership to you know
obviously one of the big challenges with
electric cars is charging stations and
there's a whole infrastructure that goes
with that on both for private usage of
electric cars and in public
transportation do you see that going
anywhere or are we sort of in the
natural gas right now what's what's the
future there is there potential for you
know leadership to to build that
infrastructure marked client if he were
here today who's with clean energy which
would give these statistics on the
natural gas vehicle adoption in Europe
and elsewhere which is very impressive
the the US is way behind in terms of
natural gas vehicles bill as a leader to
put his fleet here on natural gas it's
slow to to develop it's the right thing
to do for many of many reasons we have
been running natural gas on
on our buses for some time for electric
there it's it's it's the two part of
problem one is the the cost of the
vehicles and the and the battery and the
battery costs to develop those and we're
still seeing development in that regard
to try to bring down those prices that
make it something that you'll see widely
use the numbers are not nearly as
encouraging as they are and in
alternative fuels like natural gas in
terms of widespread adoption because the
battery costs we worked with people like
Shai Agassi who I spent time with with
when he was had raised eight hundred
million dollars for a better place
business which ultimately failed which
was battery switching batteries in
vehicles he couldn't get a manufacturer
too many really manufacture he got one
but no one in the US Tesla is a great
car the price point is coming down
Tesla's is saying that they will have
battery switching and they will have a
lot of stations but in terms of impact
on transportation industry we're also
talking to Chinese BYD which Warren
Buffett has a investment in we are
waiting to see whether there's going to
be a vehicle at the right price point
and and for private use for us we can
build the stations just as bill has a
fueling station for CNG we can build a
charging stations but I think it's going
to be a while for electric
it's gentlemen the front I'm Lee grant
is coordinator greater Haven Clean
Cities i can give you two examples where
electric vehicles are making some
headway and they're in the commercial
heavy duty vehicles the Proterra bus
which is a fast charge electric bus is
about to the point to where they are on
the way to becoming a major producer of
electric vehicles on their own without
government subsidies it's a 90,000
hundred-thousand-dollar bus this hybrid
buses run on the street down here or six
hundred fifty thousand dollars the
deltas you know 350 $250,000 and because
of fuel usage fuel costs that Delta is
being you know closed by electric
heavy-duty buses the other vehicles we
have operating here in Connecticut by
free la is a Smith truck it's a 2,600
GVWR box truck that carries potato chips
and they are making money on I just
talked to the representatives this
weekend and they're making money on that
vehicle because they've sized the
vehicle to haul the right commodity
potato chips don't weigh much but it all
has to do is return on investment and
mileage and it's got to be economically
feasible to work and those two examples
are working in and on the case of
abreast of the electric vehicles the
tests of vehicles making it on credits
and i'm not sure where that's going and
you but you have to go the miles and
there has to be return on investment
before it's going to be off on its own
without i'm being on the government dole
Thanks my name is Jeff old word i'm a
joint degree with the school of
management and school forestry here mark
I'm curious from your perspective what
needs to happen both in terms of
marketing and in terms of system
performance to change the public
perception of writing a bus in the US
well you know first the problem for many
bus systems are that people don't know
where they go a train a fixed rail
people feel safe getting on a bus and
knowing where it goes we have examples
of bus systems in Las Vegas the bus
system on the strip is is one of the few
systems may be the only system the
united states that actually along the
strip the double-decker bus that can pay
for itself the fare box recovery on bus
systems the united states is about forty
percent struggle cities struggle to get
forty percent fare box recovery to pay
for the operation of a bus system so at
least sixty percent is subsidized but
that when that particular service is
popular with tourists in many cities
like Baltimore we run the downtown
circulator it's a free bus that is used
by all kinds of folks working folks
students inner-city residents enormously
popular because it has a very limited
route in the downtown area more and more
cities are adopting circulator buses
that have limited routes and are very
popular I think that that one will be a
change of route design and this is
another question to take Karen's point
in terms of where where you said about
people commuting from into the city a
lot of our systems were designed
hub-and-spoke everything went into the
city and then back out now there's a lot
of commuting from suburb to suburb even
so new route design and buses are
flexible to do that they're much easier
to change the route design on the bus
than it is on a rail which is impossible
other than adding new rail route design
apps are going to be are going to be a
a way of navigating these services and
and seemed where you can get on a bus
where you can get off of us more and
more these apps are starting to show
when the bus is coming and where you're
going and then a lot of it is just
marketing and get it the more people get
out of their cars they're more than
willing to try other services and we see
new types of bus services and we're
working on some to bring new services to
cities that that haven't been done yet
and or haven't been done in years in the
US so it's a little bit of back to the
future there was a question in the back
woman in the back hello i'm andras far
well I'm with the New Haven urban design
League I was wondering if you could talk
about the pros and cons of transit
authorities versus privatizing and then
related to that is probably a question
of scale both of ridership population
and region the writer I heard the first
part the second part on the ridership
was hard to hear sorry I'm guessing that
related to the question of a Transit
Authority versus privatizing would also
be the scale of use your market mm-hmm
on this one the the first there are some
very well-run public transit systems the
united states that are a well-run and
well-funded and are innovative and so I
don't think you're going to see
widespread privatization of the majority
of bus systems where privatization is is
an enormous advantage is when a system
is struggling when there are problems
when they don't have the resources or
the ability to fix for us we have over
200 contracts across the country and so
our head of marketing was the president
of the discovery channel we can apply
resources to
New Orleans or to Nassau County or two
other other locations in terms of
marketing or marketing support that no
one location would have or have those
those resources locally there's another
aspect of in terms of being a change
agent to help bring the best of local
regional and international talent to
change one of the misnomers of
privatization and there are there are
strong opposition to privatization the
the primary opposition is either labor
unions or or some of the the bureaucrats
who are responsible to manage these
systems so there and some of the
concerns are legitimate but the biggest
concern which is really a misnomer is
the idea that you're selling off the
assets and you're giving up the assets
and that you're selling the future that
has happened if you sell a toll road or
you sell a the parking meters and cities
and what you're really doing is getting
the present value of those assets and
getting the cash this a cash-strapped
city gets the advantage of selling the
assets getting the cash upfront and then
the private sector manages it for the
future and there and that can be risky
selling off the asset but there can be
an advantage because the private sector
can do something for instance in toll
roads in marketing or pricing that maybe
the public sector would have trouble
doing because it might not be popular in
the case of running the buses for New
Orleans or the streetcars they're not
selling off the asset we are managing
the asset so if the city is not happy
with the way we're managing and the
value we're creating then they can take
back the asset and bring it back
in-house or look for another operator
that's a big advantage and one of the
things to the ridership question is we
align incentives with the with the city
and the region to grow ridership so we
take risk we which is not something that
the public agency is accustomed to we
say if we can grow ridership then we'll
have incentives to grow that ridership
we can participate and we
can put out more service if ridership
drops we have disincentives so there's a
level of accountability that doesn't
exist under the current under a publicly
run system there's one other question in
the back yes
hello and thank you I'm Francis sorry
I'm the mesc at FPS and was just
wondering how the transportation options
that cities are looking at are changing
with the changing demographics of
poverty and the sort of geographical
outlay of poverty so like suburbs are
increasingly showing the highest gains
and the poor population while a lot of
dents or urban areas are being
gentrified and how is that changing
whether people are going to trolleys or
street cars versus buses and how do you
provide services for transit dependent
communities who are increasingly further
and further from the jobs in the city
mm-hmm well from our perspective you've
identified a very very large part of our
transportation within the Greater New
Haven area and that is the lower-income
neighborhoods so we have we have
actually a very very good blend of
clients and they go you know from from
commuting passengers to lower-income
housing to tourists and two people going
to work every single day but we but but
well a lot of people depend on exactly
what you just said is as lower income
demand response transportation service
vios I also want to say that from our
perspective we are a small piece of the
transportation and Mark referred it was
as the last mile but but we are really a
service that facilitates everybody's
needs from you know with for instance we
service all the transportation hubs so
somebody in a lower income area may need
a short ride like a three-quarter mile
ride just to get to the bus service
that's what they rely on us for somebody
to get to the train station so we were
feeder we act as a feeder service to all
those transportation hubs and largely
the good base of our work that has been
one of the things that have made our
company successful is exactly that
population I think that I think that as
as they get stretched which is what you
suggested you know more and more on
their budgets I think that that tends to
push a lot of people back into a Carlos
situation and that results in better
better you toes
asian of mass transit to which we offer
that small piece jock just add one thing
that we talked about the the movement
back to cities and and that movement to
cities is is both young and old and the
old r are increasingly dependent on
transportation services like what bill
operates paratransit services he does it
with flexible vehicles with these mv1
vehicles that can take people who were
ambulatory as well as people who are in
wheelchairs in these vehicles what we
are seeing is a change in because that
demographic there are new opportunities
with the aging population Jim Boyle
who's here who's in charge of the
entrepreneurial Institute was talking
about what are the big problems to solve
for health care in this country and more
and more of the services outpatient
service so if you keep people out of the
hospital but you need to do preventative
care how do you accommodate those folks
and transportation systems who are aging
with health care providers who want to
who want to have service high cost
service but on an outpatient basis it
increases the opportunity for
transportation and you know just one
other thing on that is that the one of
the biggest pushes in Connecticut from
from the governor's standpoint has been
to take the aging population out of
nursing homes and put them back into
homes with our self sufficient and many
of them can do that except for there's a
big transportation component they can't
get out and travel whenever they want to
and that really is is one of the guy
pushing factors of us creating these
this massive where I consider massive
wheelchair accessible demand response
transportation so somebody either I in a
wheelchair or let's just say they use a
walker it is far easier to move up and
down one of our ramps to get in the
vehicle than it is stepping up into a
van or sinking down into a Crown
Victoria you can't get out of because it
just not conducive for that so that is
that that that right there the
accessible transportation
becoming a very very large part of our
of our client base and when bills
drivers and my drivers figure out how to
take their blood pressure and make sure
that they take their medicine we'll
really have a great business there
because we'll go out there and transport
them but will also take care of their
home health care okay we have time for
one more question there is a woman up in
the front with a green shirt with
question Oh actually their microphone is
on its way hi I'm I'm Melinda to who's
I'm an activist with elm city cycling
which promotes cycling as transportation
and recreation but I actually I had a
question for mark about the light rail
and my understanding in Jerusalem fit
veolia built a light rail that brings
people from the settlements in the West
Bank into the city and it's very
controversial and people from the West
West Bank cannot use it and I was
reading some background material that
violi was set to sell it or you know get
out of that business but as of april of
this year what you still veolia still
own it I don't know if you're connected
to that piece of it or could you just
explain that in what what's going on
with with that light rail system sure
I'm not an expert on it because I don't
operate that it's not in my area but we
do have a light rail system that is in
Jerusalem it does serve both folks who
are in the settlements and other parts
of Jerusalem it is not operated on some
discriminatory basis where it only takes
Israeli citizens the more controversial
issue was a bus system and a bus system
that was operated that went into the
settlements and so some were concerned
about that that it served the
settlements and in fact violi has sold
that bus system in the last month but
it's a subject that I would be happy to
discuss a lot of political questions
about that
and I'd be happy to talk to you
afterwards that's correct that's correct
well one of the other themes that I've
caught from this afternoon's discussion
is the the theme of getting people out
of their cars and uh and and getting
them into taxis or alternative modes of
transportation and our choice of
transportation a lot of people think is
income driven but also the research
shows that cities and countries with
very similar levels of income actually
have very different preferences for
transportation that our choice of
transportation is really shaped by
social norms and it seems that one of
the things that we're really seeing in
the last five ten years a major shifts
in social norms around transportation
bike-sharing use of taxis and other
types of transportation so I think what
we're going to see in the next 10 20 30
years certainly in the US and in
developing countries is a new
opportunities for innovation in this
area and in this industry so I want to
thank both mark and Bill and please join
me in thanking them for their insights
area to be it poor kid
you